- [Instructor] A public opinion survey
investigated whether a majority,
more than 50 % of adults,
supported a tax increase to help fund
the local school system.
A random sample of 200 adults
showed that 113 of those sampled
supported the tax increase.
Researchers used these results to test
the null hypothesis is
that the proportion is 0.5.
The alternative hypothesis is that
it's greater than 0.5 where
P is the true proportion
of adults that support the tax increase.
They calculated a test statistic of Z
is approximately equal to
1.84 and a corresponding
P value of approximately 0.033.
Assuming the conditions
for inference were met,
which of these is an
appropriate conclusion?
And we have our four conclusions here.
At any point in encourage
you to pause this video
and see if you can answer it for yourself,
but now we will do it together.
And just to make sure we
understand what's going on,
before we even cut to the
chase and get to the answer.
So what we do is we have this population
and we are going to sample it.
So N is equal to 200.
From that sample we can calculate
a sample proportion of adults
that support the tax increase.
We see 113 out of 200 support it,
which is going to be equal to,
let's see that is the same thing as 56.5%.
So 56.5% and so the key is
to figure out the P value.
What is the probability of getting
a result this much above the assumed
proportion or greater,
at least this much above
the assumed proportion?
If we assume that the
null hypothesis is true.
And if that probability,
if that P value is below
a preset threshold,
if it's below our significance level,
they haven't told it to us yet,
it looks like they're gonna
give some in the choices,
well then we would reject
the null hypothesis
which would suggest the alternative.
If the P value is not lower than this,
then we will fail to
reject the null hypothesis.
Now to calculate that P value,
to calculate that probability,
what we figure out is how many
in our sampling distribution,
how many standard deviations above
the mean of the sampling distribution
and the mean of the sampling distribution
would be our assumed
population proportion,
how many standard deviations above
that mean is this right over here?
And that is what this test statistic is.
And then we can use this
to look at a Z table
and say all right,
well in a normal
distribution what percentage
or what is the area under the normal curve
that is further than
1.84 standard deviations
or at least 1.84 or
more standard deviations
above the mean?
And they did for us as well.
So really what we just need to do
is compare this P value right over here
to the significance level.
If the P value is less than
our significance level,
then we reject,
reject our null hypothesis.
And that would suggest the alternative.
If this is not true,
then we would fail to
reject the null hypothesis.
So let's look at these choices
and if you didn't answer
it the first time,
I encourage you to pause the video again.
So at the alpha is equal
to 0.01 significance level,
they should conclude that more than 50%
of adults support the tax increase.
So if the alpha is 100th,
the P value right over here is over 300th.
It's roughly 3.3%.
So this is a situation where our P value,
our P value is greater
than or equal to alpha.
In fact it's definitely
greater than alpha here
and so here we would fail to reject,
we would fail to reject
our null hypothesis.
And so we wouldn't
conclude that more than 50%
of adults supported the tax increase.
'cause remember our null
hypothesis is that 50% do
and we're failing to reject this.
So that's not gonna be true.
At that same significance level,
they should conclude that less than 50%
of adults support the tax increase.
No, we can't say that either.
We just failed to reject
this null hypothesis
that the true proportion is 50%.
So at the alpha equals to
500th significance level,
they should conclude that more than 50%
of adults support the tax increase.
Well yeah,
in this situation we have our P value
which is 0.033.
It is indeed less than
our significance level.
In which case we reject,
reject the null hypothesis.
And if we reject the null hypothesis,
that would suggest the alternative.
That the true proportion
is greater than 50%.
And so I would pick this
choice right over here.
And then choice D at that
same significance level,
they should conclude that less than 50%
of adults support the tax increase.
No, not the situation at all.
If we're rejecting our null
hypothesis right over here,
then it should suggest this alternative.